[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens les transports en
commun je trouve ça
utile pour moi ouais pourquoi parce que
ça m'évite d'avoir une voiture je me
déplace très vite et votre frère il en
pense quoi
ça me fait elles sont pas là haut
celui-là au calme on est là ça vaut pas
toi fédéraux la magnifique c'est les
données lissées pour qui c'est pour
assurer la mena qu'est ce que vous
pensez transports en commun parisiens
je trouve très efficace j'aime beaucoup
les transports en commun et je circule
beaucoup de à paris le quartier est
votre frère il en pense quoi
qui ça notre ère une frère chez votre
frère
c'est quoi ce truc des paluds sécurité
non mais du pôle transport oui ça
dessert de partout ça les serres de
partout devrait dire oui on n importe
quel je prends n'importe quelle heure
mais je prends rarement et votre frère
ils en pensent quoi à m'en faire faut
demander à ma mère qu'il n'a pas fait ou
qui l'a pas dit alors je trouve assez
bien répartis sur le territoire avec une
fréquence que quand même vraiment
intéressante parce que j'ai vu un petit
peu différente puisqu'il nous a confondu
en fait ont ils ont échangé les s'est
levé jean ah non non non non plus pour
des frangins ils ont confondu me citer
une calzone nous c'est la bonne moi
c'est la truffe et celle ci je lâche pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]